[MUSIC PLAYING]
DON DODGE: Hi, I'm Don Dodge,
and this is "Google Root
Access." Today we're going to
talk about open source--
how Google uses open source, and
how Google contributes to
open source.
My guest today is Chris DiBona,
who runs the Open
Source Projects for Google.
Welcome, Chris.
CHRIS DIBONA: Thanks, Don.
DON DODGE: So tell me, what
do you do at Google?
CHRIS DIBONA: So very basically,
if there's open
source at Google it's my
job and my team's job
to look after it.
And that includes all the code
we might use when creating
sites like google.com, and
Gmail, and all the docs and
spreadsheets and apps
that we have online.
But also all the things
that we ship--
things like Android
and Chrome.
And if you have a Nexus device,
or if you're one of
the people who is a Google Glass
beta tester, you'll be
running open source
code on there.
Whether as part of the
proprietary software running
on top of it, or as a whole
open source ecosystem like
Android and Chrome.
So we make sure that we ship
things within compliance of
those licenses, but also so that
those teams have correct
infrastructure as well.
So we look after all kinds of
infrastructure for Android and
some of the other
teams right now.
DON DODGE: So some people may
not know this, but Google's
roots are actually
in open source.
Google built its own servers
and used Linux, and hacked
Linux to do very interesting
things.
Can you tell us a little
about that?
CHRIS DIBONA: Sure.
Well, actually, if you look back
to when Larry and Sergey
were at Stanford and building
BackRub, which of course
became Google.
That was all written in Python
and using some fairly standard
web serving tools and libraries,
and they put the
uniqueness that was
Google on that.
So you had Python running on top
of Linux, running on top
of all kinds and all
manner of hardware.
And as we grew up as a company,
we kept that ethos
where we would get what a lot
of people would consider
fairly trashy hardware, and we
would get our reliability from
the software layer.
And that was Linux, and that
was Python, and that was
eventually Java and
C and the rest.
And so we started with open
source in a lot of ways and
built on top of it, and it's
been a pretty healthy code
system since then.
DON DODGE: So Google not only
uses open source and used it
to build the base of Google, the
infrastructure of Google,
but Google also contributes
to open source?
CHRIS DIBONA: Yeah, to date
we've conservatively estimated
that we've contributed from
Google Developers about 50
million lines of code,
give or take.
And that spans everything from
Android and Chromium, all the
way through to compilers.
For instance, if you have any
consumer electronics device
that's been made in the last
five years, you're probably
running some Google code on it
and you don't even know it,
through the libraries that we've
contributed to and just
the vast number of projects
we've released,
so it's fairly shocking.
And this is not even taking
into account the vast
proliferation of Android, and
the technology inside Android.
DON DODGE: So the infrastructure
things--
BigTable and Hadoop.
Tell us a little bit about how
that evolved and what are some
of those open source projects
that either came out of
BigTable in Google's
infrastructure, or were
modeled after that.
CHRIS DIBONA: Yeah, so if you
look at Hadoop, we published a
paper back in 2000, I want to
say 2002 or 2003, about the
Google File System which
is called GFS.
And it inspired folks like Doug
Cutting to go out and
write open source
implementations of this
technology.
And that happens with a lot
of the things that we do
publications about, but
don't actually ship
as open source software.
So what you see coming from
Google is often, if we talk
about it, people will want it.
And if we don't release it
as open source, they'll
try to create it.
That's actually really
healthy.
And so you've seen a
proliferation of these kinds
of big data tools like MongoDB
and Redis and LevelDB and all
these really interesting
large-scale key
value stores and stuff.
And they have their roots in us
publishing papers about our
internal systems like BigTable
and NGFS and
Spanner and the rest.
DON DODGE: You mentioned
Chromium, Android, and some
other pretty major open source
products that Google has.
Are they licensed the same and
they are basically the same?
Or are they quite different
in how we handle them?
CHRIS DIBONA: So Chromium
and Android are
actually quite different.
If you look at Chromium, when
we wrote it we really wanted
to inspire other browser
manufacturers to, frankly, do
what we do.
And so we wanted to make it
possible for them to actually
use our code.
So beyond just contributing
to WebKit, we also made a
conscious decision to license
Chromium under BSD.
Because that code would then
be consumable by not just
WebKit-based browsers, but also
those of them that might
use Gecko, Mozilla.
Even Microsoft could take that
code and pull it into their
browser or their software, and
not just learn, but actually
just use what we're
publishing.
Because when we shipped
Chromium--
this is something a lot of
people don't understand-- when
we first shipped to Chrome and
Chromium, this was a time when
one tab getting slow would take
down your whole browser.
And we weren't really taking
advantage of the full
capabilities of a modern
CPU or modern hardware.
And so we really wanted to bring
that kind of processed
isolation, and also the security
in a sandbox to the
browser so that people could
feel the browser was a safe
place to work and to consume
information.
So we tried to convince other
browser manufacturers that
this was really important.
And we decided that it was time
to just do it, and do it
in such a way that they could,
if they ended up agreeing with
us later, just adopt the work.
And we've been moderately
successful
with that later mission.
But I think Chromium has been
very successful at showing
that you can take real advantage
of processed
isolation and sandboxing to
secure a web browser.
And I think that's really
important, and people miss
that all the time.
Now, Android's a different
story together.
With Android, we licensed
Android under the Apache
license with the kernel being
the GPL Linux kernel.
And we chose Apache for
a number of reasons.
Apache has this really awesome
language around patents.
So it says, hey, if you're using
our software and we have
patents that read on that
software, we're not going to
come and rent seek against
you for that software
unless you sue us.
So if you sue us, we're going
to retain the rights to use
those patents in the defense
of our company against you.
But otherwise, we're telling you
that you have nothing to
fear from Google and
from using Android.
And that was a really big deal,
and I think it really
mattered with the carriers.
Also, Apache has this unusual
aspect to it in the world of
open source where it says we
just want you to acknowledge
you're using it.
We don't need you to share
your source code, too.
And for the carriers who have
a lot of balls that they
juggle in the air at one time,
making compliance easier for
them is very important.
And I think it has a lot to do
with why Android is as popular
as it is with so many
manufacturers, and you know
that it's a real open
source project.
So companies will often
say hey, I've got
this open source thing.
And then you'll see that they're
the only ones running
it, and the only ones who
will ever run it.
And it comes down to trust,
and it comes down to what
license they use.
I think it's extremely telling
that when you look at a
Kindle, or you look at a Nook,
or you look at half a dozen
Android-based devices
that don't have
anything to do with Google.
That they continue to persistent
and exist, because
that's really open source.
We can't stop them, and
nor do we want to.
But even if we wanted to, we
couldn't stop them from using
the software.
And that's how you know it's
really open source.
DON DODGE: So I sort of
understand how open source
works and what it is.
But I'm confused about this
jumble of licenses, there's an
alphabet soup of licenses.
CHRIS DIBONA: You're
not alone.
DON DODGE: Can you say a little
bit about what are the
major licenses and
differences?
CHRIS DIBONA: Well, there's
three major
categories of licenses.
There's what we call the
permissive licenses, and they
basically say, here's some
code, Don, enjoy it.
And all we really ask from you
is that you mark in your about
box or in your documentation
that you're using it.
So those are the
permissive/notification licenses.
DON DODGE: What are some
examples of the [INAUDIBLE]?
CHRIS DIBONA: So that would be
BSD, that would be Apache,
MIT, ones like that.
And then there are the more
share alike style licenses.
And they say if I give my
software to Don and Don ships
something, well, then
he's obligated to
share his code, too.
For some definition of
share and use and all
the rest, of course.
But those are your GPL licenses,
your LGPL licenses,
and to a lesser degree the MPL
licenses as part of the
Mozilla tri-license.
So depending on which one it is,
you'd either have to share
more or less code, depending on
how you use that software.
And this stuff is deeply
confusing, so you shouldn't
feel like you're ignorant
of this stuff--
almost everyone is.
And it's not just a jobs program
for me and people like
me, it's just complicated
stuff.
Because these licenses, they
say how people feel about
sharing their software.
And when you talk about
feelings, things get confusing
and complicated.
And then the third category of
licenses are the ones that are
trying to also define network
performance as being the kind
of sharing that invokes the
resharing of software.
So there are very few of these,
and they're applied to
very few actual pieces
of software.
But it's a version of
the GPL called the
Affero GPL, or the AGPL.
And so, for instance, we don't
use any AGPL software at
Google and we don't
allow it here.
And that would be like
MongoDB, and
RStudio and the rest.
And so in those cases, we either
purchase a commercial
license from those software
companies or we simply don't
allow them.
DON DODGE: So the AGPL, we
don't use that because--?
CHRIS DIBONA: Because as it
interacts with other software
and then is displayed on, say,
a google.com site or on a
Gmail or apps site, we would
then have to share more
software than we're comfortable
sharing through
the linking to that software.
DON DODGE: So if I'm a startup
and I'm building my company,
what do I need to look out for
in terms of using open source?
And which license should I have,
and that kind of thing?
CHRIS DIBONA: Well, except for
the AGPL, you pretty much
don't have anything to worry
about as, say, a web startup.
If you're going to be shipping
software, that's a somewhat
longer conversation where you
try to suss out what the
startup wants to do, what
they're shipping, what they
want to share.
Because open source is, in my
mind, also a fundamental part
of a developer relations
strategy
and a developer ecosystem.
Without it you don't
have one, or it's a
very unfair one, frankly.
So what I tell startups when I
advise them is that when you
bring software into the company
that isn't written by
someone at the company, and
that means anything--
examples, software from places
like GitHub, or Stack
Exchange, or Stack Overflow--
you should always put these in
a special directory, like a
third party directory.
This is what we do at
Google, by the way.
We have millions of
these directories
all over the place.
Segregate the code--
you can absolutely,
unconditionally still use it,
you just want to keep it
out in a special place.
DON DODGE: In your code base
you actually segregate the
open source code and
you keep it there?
CHRIS DIBONA: Yeah.
And so you have these third
party directories and then you
call that code in whatever way
you see fit, but then at least
you know where it is.
So there are other hygiene
things you can do, like make
sure you only have one version
of a specific library, even if
it's used across multiple
products.
Keeping up to date with security
[INAUDIBLE], all
these things that are
fundamental to development.
But keeping things separate
enough that you can keep on
identifying it is
pretty amazing.
If you have that, you're
better than 90% of the
companies out there.
DON DODGE: So that's
rule number one?
CHRIS DIBONA: That's
rule number one.
You have to be careful
with the AGPL.
So for instance, a lot of people
really like MongoDB
right now for what it does, and
that makes perfect sense.
And if you look at how MongoDB
is licensed and the way they
articulate that license,
it's very clever.
They have very smart client
licensing, which basically
doesn't transfer that network
obligation onto a website.
But the database itself is
something you have to, if you
make improvements to the
database, if you have certain
code interacting with the
database in certain ways, that
code may end up being shared.
So you'll just want to know that
when you're using tools
like MongoDB.
Magento is another really
popular shopping cart
application.
And it's not unfair to say
that this drives a lot of
license revenue to Magento and
MongoDB, and it's fair and
this is their deal.
They're saying listen, we want
you to use this stuff.
But if you use it in certain
ways, you should be paying us.
And so that's a commercial
software license that you
would get from them.
So that's the sort of thing we
see in acquisitions actually
quite a bit.
DON DODGE: Good point.
You also review acquisitions
for Google.
Every time Google does an
acquisition, you look at the
code and look for open source,
make sure it's licensed.
So say a little bit about what
you do in that process.
CHRIS DIBONA: Yeah, so for
instance, suppose you're a
startup that does something
with video.
You're probably using FFmpeg,
you're probably using it with
certain compile flags.
And most people don't even
know this, by the way.
At this point, by the time I
say compile flags, it means
there's a developer inside that
organization who built
that piece of software.
And I can actually tell from
the output that I, the
consumer, can see pretty
much what you've done.
So it's very easy for me to say,
OK, you're probably using
this, this, and this.
And they're like, who told
you what we're using?
And it's like, we know.
We've seen a million startups
like this, and so here's what
you'll have to do to be
compliant with these licenses.
So we have that discussion a
lot with companies, by deal
close you have to
do X, Y, and Z.
And it's funny, when I was
younger and maybe more
idealistic or less cynical, I
would say, I can't believe
these people are breaking
licenses in such
a fundamental way.
But what it is is most people's
intentions are pure.
They just don't know how to be
compliant with these licenses,
and sometimes it's actually
deeply complicated.
So oftentimes when we see
acquisitions come in, we'll
say, OK, if you want to keep
shipping this piece of
software, you have to do X and
Y and Z. And you've been
shipping this piece of software
for this long, so
you'll need to do this.
So that people who want their
rights under the open source
licenses which you have chosen
to use are going to be able to
be satisfied.
Because we like to in some
ways over-comply.
Put up mirrors of code so
that people can find the
information they want about open
source in your product
simply by googling for it.
It saves us a lot of time than
having to answer emails and
sit on mailing lists and worry
a lot about things.
So we try to bring people into
our level of compliance, which
is very high, by the
time a deal closes.
We've never had to scuttle a an
acquisition because of this.
I've seen acquisitions fall
apart, and this might be a
component of that, but
it's very rare.
It's more that bringing
discipline to your code base
for open source really has
higher implications about the
quality of the code
of the company.
DON DODGE: Overall?
CHRIS DIBONA: Yeah, exactly.
So it's extremely rare
to find somebody who
understands this stuff.
What's the right way
to say this?
If someone has a good, tidy
code base, then they're
usually also either very
compliant with open source
licenses already, or easily
able to become compliant.
If they're not compliant with
open source licenses and they
have an untidy code base, that
could have implications, too,
during an acquisition that have
nothing to do with the
open source license compliance
and everything to do with how
they develop and how they
bring software together.
It's more of an indicator.
DON DODGE: So if a startup is
using MongoDB, or Magento--
CHRIS DIBONA: Which a lot are.
It's a great tool.
They're both great tools.
DON DODGE: So what
happens then?
We just don't consider using
that kind of software?
CHRIS DIBONA: In rare cases we
have a pool of licenses for
them to draw upon, but we
keep that very limited.
Because usually when people come
to Google, they end up
transferring onto our technology
or we're shutting
their technology off.
It depends on the situation.
It's very hard to say we always
do X or we always do Y.
Because we want to remain
flexible for
these kinds of things.
There are some companies, and
I'm not going to name them,
where if you have GPL software
they will simply force you to
rip it out before they'll even
talk to you, much less let the
deal close.
So it's rare nowadays, but
it certainly happens.
And I'm not talking about
the Linux kernel.
Everyone's comfortable with
It's sort of an accepted
thing that they have
to deal with that.
But for some GPL tools and
system libraries and web
frameworks and stuff,
they don't want
to have that around.
DON DODGE: Well, that's really
a competitive advantage for
Google and it has been
from the beginning.
CHRIS DIBONA: I would
consider it so.
Yeah.
For instance, if you reject all
GPL and LGPL code, you're
rejecting 75% of the open source
code that's out there.
And we're talking, I think it
was probably 35 million unique
files out there encompassing
maybe 5 billion lines of code.
So you would be rejecting 75%
of that just by saying, I
don't want to deal with
the GPL and the LGPL.
Again, it's a fine
decision to make.
I think it's very limiting.
DON DODGE: So Google roots are
in open source and we use open
source, we contribute
to open source.
CHRIS DIBONA: We create new open
source developers with
the Summer of Code.
I mean, we do a lot.
DON DODGE: Say more about
the Summer of Code.
You've been writing that program
for quite a while.
CHRIS DIBONA: Yeah, we're
coming up on our
ninth year, I believe.
And what that does is it
basically introduces students
to open source software.
It sets up a one-to-one
mentoring relationship between
open source software projects
and students.
So the idea was Larry Page was
uncomfortable that people were
leaving college for the summer
and then backsliding over the
summer because they had to
go get a job that wasn't
computer-related.
So he was like, if you could fix
that, that would be great.
And I was like, OK.
So we came up with the
Summer of Code as a
way of fixing that.
And the idea was we would give
people real world, real bug,
real problem experience
in open source.
And it would also expose them
to the world of open source
development.
I think that's been
an incredible good
for computer science.
We've only taken about
10,000 students
through the program now.
DON DODGE: 10,000?
That's a lot.
CHRIS DIBONA: Yeah.
10,000, 9,000, yeah,
about that.
And we pay them over the
summer to do this work.
DON DODGE: So they actually
get paid to do this?
CHRIS DIBONA: Yeah.
We spend a fair amount
of money.
And they on average write about
3,000 lines of code that
ends up into open
source software.
So you can do the math
there, too--
it's a significant
amount of code.
When you're a computer
science student--
I don't know if you went through
CS school-- but you're
taught a lot of theory and a lot
of comparative programing
languages and algorithms
and that kind of thing.
You're not taught what
happens when a
user uses your software.
You're not taught what happens
when they decide to run it on
some horrible piece
of trash computer
that you never expected.
And open source software
projects are exposed to that
kind of real world usage
all the time.
And so you get a whole different
view into how to
make a software program work and
what users need by working
on open source.
And additionally, this is not
a we bring them into Google
and host them kind of program.
This is a wherever they are
all over the world.
We've done this in
93 countries now.
DON DODGE: Really?
CHRIS DIBONA: And paying
people in 93
countries is not easy.
But we've had students in pretty
much any country you
can think of in the
modern world.
Well, perhaps there's more
now that there's 273
countries in the UN.
It's been pretty remarkable to
see how these students turn
from these neophyte programmers,
really, into
pretty amazing remote
programmers, which frankly is
something that industry
struggles with.
Having remote developers is
extremely difficult, and open
source seems to figure it out.
And what it comes down to,
really, is the people who are
good at that kind of thing are
good at open source, and the
people who aren't, aren't.
So we had the failure mechanism
in the Summer of
Code as well where we probably
fail about 14%, 15% of the
students every year out
of the program.
And that means they
don't get paid at
some step of the program.
So maybe they'll get the
acceptance fee, but not the
mid-term or the final payment.
So it's very merit-based which
is also, I think, a key thing
about open source.
You either do a good job or
you're not part of it.
DON DODGE: Fascinating.
Well, thank you.
Thank you for being here today
and for your contributions to
open source at Google.
CHRIS DIBONA: Absolutely.
DON DODGE: It's terrific.
CHRIS DIBONA: Thanks
for having me.
DON DODGE: Thank
you very much.
Thank you for joining us.
And be with us next time on
"Google Root Access," when
we'll be talking about how
startups can use open source.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]